foreign
[Music]
giant shark is not enough in Meg 2 the
trench we can look forward to tons of
sea monsters Not only was there new
images to see but the director also
talked about the future of the film
series it all started in 2018 with the
surprise hit Meg directed by John
turtletop the action Blockbuster with
Jason Statham grossed an impressive 527
million dollars on a budget of 130
million dollars so it's hardly
surprising that they wanted to add to IT
director Ben Wheatley who has already
demonstrated his talent for particularly
vicious films with kill list high-rise
and free fire took on the task of
directing the sequel in an interview
with total film magazine he talked about
his further Ambitions Meg 3 is
absolutely on his bucket list he
believes there is still a lot to explore
in this franchise he was especially
excited by the international nature of
the movie series here people from the
most diverse parts of the world gathered
to face a problem together which is a
fantastic message for the audience
however the viewers are sure to want to
see one thing Above All Else gigantic
monsters in action in Meg 2 Jason
Statham Alias Jonas Taylor and his
research team head for the unknown
depths of the ocean where they clash
with a ruthless company in search of raw
materials but the bigger problem is soon
to come as a multitude of monsters are
set loose which then head for the
surface and the tourists there the level
of excitement for Meg 2 has already
risen considerably since the first
trailer new posters now make us want to
see the fun monster movie even more on
one of them not only do we see that
Jonas and the others have to deal with
several Megs at once but there is also
gigantic tentacles reaching into the
picture the Chinese poster however is
really fancy and presents the film in a
very unique style we can't wait for the
release of Meg 2 the trench on August
4th 2023 should the movie be able to
match the success of its predecessor a
make-3 seems highly likely after all the
original book series by author Steve
Alton consists of a total of eight
volumes
thank you
[Music]
foreign